hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcasts exploring
pharmacological interactions in food
matrix the innovations and challenges of
n cats drug combinations HTS platform
presented by dr. Kelly Wilson who should
scientist in the information technology
research branch at the National Center
for advancing translational science and
cats at the NIH
I am margerine Torrance applauses and
Alvin your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
lattice sybiz facility scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions if you are
at anytime you want during the
presentation just click on the green
humanoid button located in the lower
left of the presentation window and type
your questions in the box that appears
on the screen well answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also please notice
that you will be feeling the
presentation when it slides in though to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
subscribe button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem
this presentation is educational and
best authors continuing education
credits please click on the button in
the bottom left corner and follow the
process of tinea pedis
please join me in welcoming dr. Kelly
Walton I will now turn the presentation
over to her thanks Tiffany for that
introduction and so important we're
going to get started now with my talk
which is entitled exploring
pharmacological interactions with matrix
innovations and challenges of impact
drug combinations HTS plastic
so the talk that I'll be giving today is
just a brief outline um so I'll just
give you a brief introduction to impact
the Institute at the NIH I work at for
those that don't know about it then I'll
talk about reasons why you may want to
implement combination - screaming or
CHCs as I'll refer to it today and the
requirement that you would need to
implement this type of platform in your
own institution then I'll talk some
about acoustic distancing challenges and
solutions also talk about our screening
workflow and some considerations you'll
need before starting and also some of
the challenges and solutions we have
developed here for data analysis and
lastly I'll give a couple of examples of
scientific questions where you can apply
drug combination screening to really
understand drug basic biology or to try
and explore drug repurposing for various
disease types and then that will be used
the end of the talk so let's get started
first you may be wondering what is
impact
so impacts is one of the newer NIH
Institute's and it stands for the
National Center for advancing
translational science and the mission of
impact is to catalyze the generation of
innovative methods and technologies that
will enhance the development testing and
implementation of diagnostics and
therapeutics across a wide range of
human diseases and conditions and today
on the top that I'll be giving is really
focused oh excuse me on the innovative
methods and technologies on development
that we've done here and so in cat
basically is structured on as far as
multiple groups this is just on your
typical Pharma pipeline where you start
with a target for your particular
disease and then from there you move
down this line towards a hopefully FDA
approval and so the group that I'll talk
to you about today is really focused on
working in the space around half a
development prob'ly development
and lead optimization leading up to
three clinical development and so
hopefully today you'll learn a little
bit about what we do it in task and
we're a highly collaborative Institute
even though we have lots of groups
within the impact umbrella from all of
you searched our collaborative we have a
stem cell technology facility we also
have an RNAi eye screening group so
there are many many opportunities for
collaboration with in impact and so if
anyone is interested in learning more
about that up yes please feel free to
contact me about that and I can try to
direct you to the proper group so then
let's move on to why would you want to
use this combination drug single
platform and the goal um for our program
has been to look for novel drug
synergies and I'll talk about what
exactly drug synergy is but there are
lots of applicable uses of this platform
so you may have an interest in drug
repurposing so many diseases cancer
various infectious diseases are already
treated by combining multiple drugs and
giving those to a patient at the same
time to achieve the best possible
efficacy so you may want to increase
efficacy you all you also may want to
attenuate toxicity often times Road
giving it very high doses are very toxic
possibly if you found two drugs that
acted very well together you may be able
to lower the dose of those those drugs
and therefore reduce toxic side effects
but this abscess platform can also be
applied on to basic research interests
so if you have an interest in a certain
signaling pathway and how that may
interact with other signaling pathways
within a cell or within some biological
system using combining two inhibitors of
both of those pathways may give you some
insight into how those pathways are
interacting with each with each other
and feedback loops you may also want to
explore poly pharmacology so there are
many drugs that have multiple mechanisms
of
action and those will be poly
pharmacology drugs and those he were to
use those for drug screening you combine
two drugs together maybe one you know
the target and the other one you are
unaware of the target doing a drug
combination study may be able to help
you understand more about the target of
that drug which unknown mechanism of
action so then what do you need to set
up this type of platform and so on the
basic requirement that we kind of
started with are very simple but it
required a lot of in-house development
and a lot of people with different
expertise to get this platform off the
ground to the point where it is now and
so the three requirements that are
really important for this is number one
you need to have compounds with a
defined mechanistic class on or targets
on so compounds that you have a good
idea of what they what they what the
structure those compounds are you need
to be able to say that they are very
good at targeting these specific protein
or this specific types of interactions
in a Cell the second requirement that is
important for this type of platform is
you have to have a flexible and accurate
compound plating technology and the
flexibility aspect is very very
important that you'll see in the
presentation and then lastly you need a
data analysis platform that can mitigate
assay artifacts which is key for any
sort of type of constraining but you
also want to be able to use the data in
an easy way and allow your collaborators
to view the data in a way that's
meaningful and also you want a way to
write synergistic combination and he
wish wants to move forward with for
follow-up screaming and additional
experimentation so starting with the
first one of compounds with define
mechanistic pathogen or target we at
impact has many many in-house drug
libraries that have been developed from
using commercially available compounds
some with collaborations with
pharmaceutical companies
or they supply compounds but one of our
really common drug libraries that we use
for our CHCH TTS platform is the mic
library and might stands for mechanism
interrogation place and that is just a
name that we applied to this library to
say that there's multiple mechanisms on
this plate or in this drug library so
there's 1912 small molecule in this
library all of those compounds are
plated at an 11 point dose response
curve and there's a range of
investigational and approved compounds
in this library but the real strength of
mic is that it is fully annotated and so
as you can see this image is just
demonstrating some of the compounds that
are in might for example this Valena
stat is an H stack inhibitor that is
currently in phase on 2 & 3 and this is
one H stack inhibitor but there are many
HVAC inhibitors within that class that
exists and so what we've done in life is
you have put all of the ACE inhibitors
that are commercially available into
this library so they're approximately 20
H stack inhibitors in mind so the
mechanisms of action are redundant
because what that allows is that you can
screen multiple compounds that text that
are supposed to have the same mechanism
or the same drug target and see how all
of those performs in that assay to kind
of get an understanding of whether those
mechanisms are really accurate across
all those compounds and that is a way
that you can use this combination
platform to really try to understand
basic biology and the clinical relevance
so we have an excellent library of small
molecules and that's one of the main
requirements so then let's talk about on
drug synergy and why exactly on what
what exactly is synergy on so the
definition of drug synergy it's actually
quite simple
it's a
plus B or a minus C pretty much any
mathematical operation of a and B and is
that greater than what you would expect
a so a simple math problem is if a is 7
and B is 3 if you add a plus B you
should get 10 that is what you would
stick but if you added 7 plus 3 and got
14 that would be synergy because that is
greater than what you expected um so I
know that that seems very simple but
that is on the basis of most formulas
and calculates energy that is basically
what it is and so one of the challenges
with trying to calculate drug synergy is
that there are multiple models that
exist and this chart here is just a
really a summary of the different models
that are available for calculating drug
synergy and there is really a very
little agreement within the field of
pharmacology about which of these models
is the best one the best thing that you
can take away from this slide is that
each of them have their strengths and
weaknesses depending on what it is that
you are trying to do with your data what
the goal of your study is and so in this
pros and cons section you can see that
on the low e model is a dose effects
base of model or calculating drug
synergy and so what you can see is that
even though it is mechanistically
well-defined and it because it is a user
sigmoid like structure in its
calculation of synergy it's not robust
because it assumes that those a and B
have a similar eMac a similar tool slope
and are and are similar it doesn't
account for the variation that could
exist between two things or two a drug
that you're combined whereas the list
model or which also can be applied to
these other formulas the HFA
gamma and data these are much more
complex and so they can
are very robust and therefore to handle
situations where the two compounds that
you're trying to combine are at
different ratios across your experiment
can be highly different on activities
that the two compounds that you're
combining but the con of that is that it
is a more noisy and also introduces more
error into into the formula using a
stable um so since synergy is something
that is there's multiple ways to
calculate it and there is not very good
agreement upon how to calculate it
um the thing that we do here at n cap is
we basically use on all of these models
use all the synergy metrics and people
our collaborators can pick and choose
which one they would like to use to
measure their synergy and I'll show you
on how we display that a little later in
the presentation but let's get back to
how how can we do this in a way that is
meaningful and will reveal drugs and how
can we combine a compound a and compound
B in a way that will reveal drug synergy
and so what our standard or what we
tried and we're first implementing this
platform is to do on a 4 by 4 matrix
lock which is pictured here and so what
you'll see is that compound a is on the
x-axis of this block and so it exists in
three doses in this 4x4 block at 8
micromolar 16 micro molar 32 micro molar
and then over here there is a always a
well that has absolutely nothing in it
or that's your DMSO control well so
compound a is plated in single agent in
this bottom column of this nature flop
compound B is plated in single agent on
the right-hand column of this nature
slot and so you can see that it is
played at a completely different on
dilution and concentration in compound a
so it's 12 6 micro moles or 6 micro
molar and 3 micro molar and so that is
how compound B is plated in single agent
in this one well and then the centre of
this law
is the is the part of the nature is the
part of the matrix block where you would
be able to see synergy if it was present
because in each well there is the
combination of the dose that is directly
of the compound a and B are in each of
these wells and so you can see the
mixing colors compound a is red compound
B is blue and so in this block you have
various shades of purple and pink
because each of those compounds is in
different ratios within this four by
four nature sauce so if you were trying
to do this in a systematic way say we
wanted to test multiple compounds all in
combination together
you can see how this could get to be a
really really large experiment that
would require a lot of resources and
time for actual compounds plating in
this format so just looking at this 4x4
block if we only wanted to do one of
these we would need 12 dispenses of drug
a by by itself to take the makeup part
of this matrix block we need 12
dispenses of drugs B to make up the rest
of this matrix block and then we would
need one well with just DMSO by itself
which is our control will so just to
make this one matrix locks someone would
need to undertake 25 dispenses or 25
pipetting steps so you can see that on
the right there is an equation for how
we calculate non-redundant matrices for
in number of [ __ ]
so you basically just take in multiply
that by n minus 1 and then divide that
by 2 and that gives you the total number
of pairwise combinations so the example
I've given you here on this slide is
let's say that you're in is 30 compounds
30 x 29 divide that by 2 that is 435
combination so in order to do 30
compounds in pairwise combination in a
four by four matrix plus you can
multiply 34 35 by 25 dispenses for each
block that is a very large amount of
petting it would be very difficult for
someone to do by hand which is why this
must be done in an automated fashion and
so that is what I'll talk about now is
how we automated this system using this
new technology and acoustic dispenser so
looking at the second bullet point we
need a flexible and accurate compound
plating technology so that is where a
clue stick dispensers come in they're
the ideal tool for this application and
on this slide on the Left I've pictured
on two acoustic sensors that are widely
used in multiple and industry in various
academic institutions and so what these
instruments do is actually a very
amazing technology on what they are able
to do is they use an acoustic sound wave
to transfer a droplet from a source
plate into another plate of destination
point and so if you'll see in this kind
of a cartoon on the right side of the
slide you have a 384-well source plate
here that is on sitting there's no lid
on it it's open and has compounds in
each of the well then at the bottom of
that in this little blue area that is
the transporter and the transporter is a
creates a wave of sound which is applied
to the bottom of that 384-well plate
that wave of sound hits a very small
area in a single weld and that sound
transfer takes a droplet which is shown
here in this small blue dot and it
transfers it straight upwards into a
1536 well on destination point and that
is how you achieve the matrix block or
the 4x4 the 4 by 4 matrix law that I've
shown here and that on your destination
plate you would program your your
acoustica sensor to transfer compound a
from a certain well into all of the
wells that will create that will contain
compound a which is here as I've shown
and risk and then you would program your
acoustica Center to transfer all of
compound B into the wells where it
should be as I've just highlighted in
red and at the end of that you also have
your offensive dispenser transfer DMSO
into the corner well so that you have a
control within your matrix lock and that
is how you achieve this platform and so
you can see that the flexibility in both
in acoustic dispensing is great because
you can literally tell it to take any
well from your source plate and put it
into any well on your destination place
um you know this is highly different
from a pencil transport transfer or some
other handler that you just chip because
typically any transfer that uses tips
it's going to be static so you can only
go from one location into the same
location on your two plates there's that
plate that you're your source plate and
your destination plate but this is
highly flexible so you can tell it to go
from one well of your source to another
will of your destination you can also
have it go do multiple dispenses from a
single well you can have it do one
dispense from every well into one well
of your destination plate the
possibilities really are endless so um
just a brief compare and contrast of the
two main acoustic dispensers or the two
most common ones EDC Biosystems makes
the ATS 100 lab site echo has three
different models of acoustic dispensers
about 25 to 550 or the 555 and so this
is this is just a brief compare and
contrast of both they both can dispense
various sizes of droplets and they both
can also dispense liquids of various
viscosity so if your compound is
suspended in something that's not DMSO
fa a-- suspended in water or glycerol or
something like that on the acoustic
energy required to transfer something in
DMSO is different than needed to
transfer us
liquid that is of a different viscosity
and so both of these instruments can do
various liquid viscosity however EDC
Biosystems requires a calibration of
each of the liquid types that you would
like to play whereas the lab side echo
that calibration is included in their
software and so there is no calibration
required you just specify which liquid
you're going to be dispensing in or
missing with and that's all repeated um
the other thing the other difference
between the EDC Biosystems 80s 100 and
the lab side echo is the EDC can use any
source at any destination place that you
would like to use brand material there
are no limitations on that last side
echo has chosen to restrict the source
plate pipes that you are able to use
that you have to get your source plates
on lab side echo so that does increase
on your consumables cost but they argue
that on the their production of the
plates is more consistent than you would
get with your using their source plates
from a lot of different companies and
then lastly there's really big software
difference between on these two
instruments so the EDC Biosystems ATS
100 the supplied software is very
bare-bones um there is not a lot of it's
not very user-friendly and it also does
not have full capabilities for setting
up matrix training it can do it can do
some of some combination screening but
it is not as advanced as the lab site
echo software is um and also the lab
light echo software is very user
friendly so it was built to be used as a
walk up instrument that a person who has
no experience and expensing could walk
up on create a protocol on their
software and do a couse efficiency in
their place and have it you know and get
all of these um everything is included
on it in their software and so this my
one of my supervisors here kind of
described the EDC by assistive aps 100
in the last five echo as
Android in the Apple of the elusive
dispensing world because the last line
echo even though it is quite user
friendly um is very limited in what you
can do with it
or as the 80s 100 on the software is
more bare-bones but that does allow for
you to do your own customization on top
of what they did on so those are just
two kind of visit just a general
comparison of the two and additionally
the last light echo is more expensive
than the 80s one depending on which
model you need for your for for your
needs so one of the challenges that we
initially had upon starting our apply
our PhDs platform is that usually what
we get from biologist before setting up
an experiment is a form like you see in
the lower right corner we get a list of
compounds and the biologist says I would
like for all of these compounds to be
combined with all of the compounds on
this list so all pairwise combinations
and these are the concentrations I want
and this is the solution curve that I
want so that's typically what we're
handed and then one of the challenge
with that is that we basically need to
take these compounds put them on a
384-well source plate in a format that
is able to plate this experiment as they
want and we also need a map generated
for this source plate the other thing
that we need is a lead formatter or a
way to actually take that 384-well plate
and say okay after my experiment is done
when I've done this plating what is not
1536 well plates going to look like
where the compounds at where is compound
Abe inflated where this compound even
plated and how is it arranged on the
plate so that our bioinformaticians can
actually do their data and the last
really critical part of this is shown in
the right is that you needed a program
that would generate the file that is
actually needed to give the on the
acoustic sensor to actually create this
this is some excuse me to actually
create a file that
is a script files that all acoustic
sensors have a file that has to be run
they have to use in order to run to know
where to play where to move to take from
this location on the source plate in the
fifth location on a destination place
and so in the lower right corner this is
just a sample script file and so you
have to have a file like this on to load
onto your acoustic sensor so that it
knows what to do and so we had an
amazing software developer in-house on
his name is dawn moon and he actually
wrote the our first automated play tree
format so what it did is you inputted a
little compound it created a map for
your 384-well source plates and it also
created a 1536 well mat for you and it
gave you all the files needed this easy
script file in order to actually run
your experiments so this was very a very
critical step without this piece of
software it would have been very
difficult for us to be able to do this
type of screen in a large scale because
there's so many files that need to be
generated so that was a very big hurdle
we had to cross so once we had gotten
past that um then we had to decide on
plating format and so what we kind of
decided on internally was that we would
do 6x6 matrix blocks and 10 by 10 matrix
plus also do a four by four earlier I'm
in an early experiments it was shown
that that was kind of too few constants
- too few concentrations needed in order
to actually have a drug synergy be
highlighted in a block and so what you
can see in this matrix the 6x6 matrix
block on your right exact same format
and the red and the black colors are for
a cell viability assay that's our
coloring scheme so anywhere you see
black that means that lots of cells are
alive in that well anywhere where you
see red that means lots of cells are are
dead in that well and this is after
sometimes 24 48 or 72 hours of drug free
so a 6x6 matrix block is five doses
of drug a here on this bottom row and
then five doses of drugs be in the side
column and then in the middle just like
in the 4 by 4 matrix block that is where
all the jet combinations are at and you
have your well of DMSO in the corner so
each matrix block takes up 36 12 ounces
then as a follow up format but basically
this is a six by six is used for kind of
a primary half a and any compounds that
look or any kind of combinations that
look synergistic there we didn't lose
those up to a 10 by 10 and so what that
does is that just makes a much larger
matrix lock and that allows us to see if
the synergistic window is is a larger or
larger than what it wasn't a successive
and so the 10 by 10 is exactly in the
same format that you have your drug a is
a non doses are on the bottom of this
nature slide block on the side is drugs
B by itself and then same thing in the
middle you have all of your combinations
of drug a and B together and your DMSO
well is in the corner and so again the
and so you can see in both of these
blocks on the area where some possible
drug synergy is happening for example if
you look at this well right here that
I've highlighted in red at 44.6%
viability you can see that in the wells
of the single agent wells both drug a
and drugs B are really doing almost
nothing there are all the cells are
alive 196 percent of the cells are alive
whereas if you combine these two doses
you get about 44 percent of the cells
left alive which is the beginning of
drug synergy and you can see in this 10
by 10 matrix lock on the synergistic
window is actually much much larger than
it is because it is a larger matrix
block so you can see in the red area
I've highlighted in this 10 by 10 that
is where the drug synergy is really
strong in this particular block
so those are the two plating formats
that we decided upon and then we
implemented our first robotic system to
automate this screening and so in our
first system this was a long time ago we
had one ABC ATS 100 we had a thermo CRF
arm for moving plates between the EDC
and a thermo rapid stack which actually
just held the plate that we would be
using for this and then we had an
Agilent plate lock and an Agilent be
spin in case we needed to seal any plate
or spin any plates on in our protocol
and the same developer software
developer that built the automated plate
reform adder also built robotics
scheduling software in-house so that we
could do large-scale screening of
multiple plates without having a person
there to move plates on and off this
platform this was our very earliest
acoustic transfer robotic system and so
um the next major hurdle that we had to
do is that that system was very
successful but the amount of screening
that we were doing it was getting larger
and larger and larger and so the
challenge that we had there is that we
had to start creating a phase where we
had multiple sources and so why do we
need multiple sources well let's say
that this is a very small list of
compounds here in the right corner
there's only about 10 or so of them here
we started to get into situations where
people were submitting a matrix
screaming where they wanted to do you
know one drug in combination with an
entire drug library so they wanted to do
one drug in combination with 2,000 drugs
and so that is a very large number of
combinations and all of those 2,000
drugs will not fit on one 384 well
socially and so what we had to do is
figure out how can we format our source
plates in a way that would allow us to
do these very large screens but also
format them in a way where we could
account for we
need more volume now because we're doing
larger screening we maybe need a higher
concentration because our stock
concentration has to be higher on to
achieve our desired final dose and so on
some of the considerations that we had
to start thinking about is in creating a
source plate is what stock
concentrations do we need to have in
that plate so that we get the desired
final concentration what volume of
compound is needed to finish the entire
screen maybe we're only transferring 10
nano liter droplets of compound in most
of our assays but if you're doing
something where you're you know neat you
have two thousand combinations you're
going to quickly move through a lot of
compounds and also do we need multiple
source plates will all the compounds fit
on a single plate or do me to expand
that over many source plates and so to
kind of get over that hurdle again we
moved to automation and software
development and so we had another
in-house developer named Tim years one
who created our automated source site
generator and so what this piece of
software does is just a screenshot from
that software and so what we what this
software does is whenever we get a list
of compounds submitted that says I want
to do all pairwise combinations of these
30 compounds um all our compound
management staff has to do is input that
list of compounds into the box that I've
highlighted here they have to fill out a
few parameters to transfer volume what's
the final assay volume what is the stock
concentration of each of the compounds
that are on this list what is the matrix
size is it a six five six is it at ten
by ten and then how many replicates of
this are we going to need is this
something where we're screening you know
five cell lines of the exact same
combination are we doing multiple assay
types you input all of that into this
first screen here make sure you fill out
your settings and then from there this
software is amazing because what it does
is it produces every single piece
information and every file type that is
needed to run that matrix so it makes
all of the source plate maps it makes
all of the destination plate maps it
also makes the script files needed for
the acoustic sensor in order to actually
place that on experiment and lastly a
lead a PerkinElmer Janis in the compound
management lab to actually create the
source plate to go from the compound
in a tube to the compounds in 384-well
plate it actually creates the jams files
that are needed on to create that source
code so this software in one shot with
minimal input makes everything that is
needed in order to plate make a source
plate make the destination plate and run
the stringing and automated fashion so
with the implementation of this new
software we are now able to do very very
large nature extremes and so now our
software had kind of Eclipse our robotic
setup so recently in the last two years
we are set up a new robotic on system
and so this is our current robotics
system so on this system there are two
acoustic dispensers both of them are
this is EC 1 and this is e DC 2 so we
have two 80s 100's on this platform and
this platform was built for us by high
res bio solutions
um also on this platform there is a
plate hotel it's really hard to see
because it's kind of underneath this
platform but it can hold 316 plates um
there is a micro centrifuge here in case
it's like you spun down there is a
litter and a div litter hotel on this
platform so plates can lids can be
removed from place there is also a plate
lock and a plate sealer here in case we
the steel plates during the assay and
there's also a barcode scanner which
allows for us keep track of all the
plates to make sure that the correct
plates are on the correct compounds are
applied to the correctly
and the software that operates the
scheduling software that operate this
entire robotic system it's called
salario and it's the most recent version
on it's a 3.2 version and this software
is actually relatively user friendly and
so this is just some of the highlights
of the salario software um one of the
things that's great with this one is you
can actually do graphical protocol
design so this is just a sample protocol
that you can create and it will show you
exactly you know what in a graphical
format what that protocol what you told
on the robot to do so in this sample
protocol the robot is going to pick up
source plate it is going to take the lid
off of the source plate and it is then
going to move it to cherry-pick and in
our case cherry pick is the is the
acoustics dispenser so it's going to
move it to the acoustic sensor and then
the next thing that it's going to do is
it's going to take to the destination
plate and pick it up from the lid hotel
it is going to this incubate step it's
just want to wait on that one of the
platforms and still the source plated in
acoustic sensor it is then going to take
the lid off of the destination place and
move it to the cherry pick which again
is a few states of sensor and then it is
going to put the lid back on the
destination plate when it's finished and
it's going to stop and then it's going
to remove the source plate to put the
lid back on the source plate move it
back to the hotel itself so you can
really see if you set up a new protocol
what exactly you hold the robot to do in
a graphical way which is really helpful
um the other thing that's great about
this is that it has simulation modes so
if you're planning a new experiment and
you're not exactly sure how long it's
going to take the plates come how
exactly how long each of the destination
is going to take the finish um this
format is really great because you can
run it in simulation mode there is a
time bar at the top of this as you can
see and it will give you you know it
started at this time your experiment
should be finished all the spotting or
the plating of the compound
um the other thing that's really helpful
here is that in this software you can
specify whether you want your assay to
be run to be sourced censored meaning
that it will keep all of the it'll keep
a destination plate on the acoustic
dispenser and it will go ahead and bring
in every source that isn't used to make
up that one destination one at a time
and then once it's finished with the
destination it will remove it put in the
next one so that is a destination
centric of assay design and then you can
also run things in a destinations are a
source censored fashion and source
centric is it's the same thing that's
going to lead one source plate on the
robot on the acoustic dispenser and it
is going to move all the destinations
and complete every destination we need
to be done with that source then it will
remove that source and put on a new
source to continue and so depending on
what type of experiment you're running
how many source pipes you have being
able to toggle between those two options
can really help speed of your experiment
um and then this is just a screenshot of
the how you create orders and so an
order is just literally a protocol
similar to what on I was shown before in
the graphical format so in this order we
have uploaded a script to plate 76 plate
um this is our source plate here all of
our destinations are spread across these
column in the lid Hotel it shows you
where all your plates are located at and
so this is one order and so you can
create orders on any way that you like
it's really nice system visualize all of
them and then you can also do order
scheduling which is really really been
great because you can link multiple
orders so that once also for example a
this order that is saying it's active
right now that means that order is
actually running at the moment but we
have scheduled this to say that as soon
as this order is complete order five
five seven zero
it's going to start on the next order
which is five five six nine so these two
orders are linked and it will just
automatically start the next one and so
what that has allowed for us to do is
that you know overnight you can you know
start acoustic spotting of an order and
it will finish when we come in the next
morning
barring any sort of error that occurs
that may occur for various reasons and
so that has actually been a really big
thing for automating this entire
platform we regularly plate 156 a unique
destination that are comprised for five
different sources placed on this robotic
system and so that is how we've adapted
this flexible and accurate compound
plating technology for our safety of
platforms and then the last major
advance that we really put a lot of work
in shoes for the data analysis analysis
platform and so I'll talk a little bit
about that and so this is our typical
workflow um and we promote for the most
part have done cell viability screening
so using cells header glow from kromega
at either 48 or 72 hours after compound
in cell addition and so we start off our
workflow with just getting single agent
dose responses and that's really
important because we need to know the
concentration ranges of the compounds so
once we have a list of asses a single
agent we are going to cherry-pick
adjust those concentrations and then run
a six by six of primary screen and so
our format current format fits about
thirty five six by six matrix blocks on
a single 1536 well plates and then once
we have looked at that done a data
analysis any compound any combinations
that appear to be synergistic we then
are going to move to a ten bucks in
follow up screen and the ten by ten
again is an expanded matrix block so you
can really zero in on where the drug
synergy is happening what concentration
raise up honey and so there's this kind
of our typical
workflow and and so what are the
important considerations before getting
started on doing
a screening platform of training
workflow in this way so one of the major
things that I think people are
underappreciated is you really think
about the what is the goal of your drug
screens you have enough hypothesis that
you want explore are you trying to be
drug repurposing what is the goal
because that is really going to dictate
what your screening strategy is and how
you'll able to be able to answer the
question that you are aiming for and
then other considerations that are
important on the so on or ins on the
assay that you're using is it expensive
is it difficult on to obtain or is it
easy to obtain because the number of
plates on that you can run through for a
typical drug combination streams can get
quite large
depending on the number of compounds
that you're using and so it can get
expensive
and so thinking about do I really need
to use this patient-derived cell line
that doesn't grow very well for this
experiment or can I try to use maybe a
model that is not quite as applicable
but is more amenable to this platform
and then also thinking about positive
and negative controls for drug synergy
are there's two compounds that in the
literature have been shown to combine to
get the outcome that you're looking for
if you can include those in your list of
compounds that you're using for
straining and that will really help you
see if the assay that you're doing is
working how do you expect there if it's
replicating previous previously
published data um and the really big
thing that is also important for setting
this up is making sure that your
concentration ranges are where they need
to be to see drug synergy and so in the
top on there the 6x6 matrix block that
I've shown you that really doesn't have
the concentration windows set correctly
um so drug a in this in this 6x6 block
the top concentration is set at 10 10
nano molar and so that seems really low
but this drug is very active and so you
can see that at 10
nano molar this compound is pretty much
killing every single cell um present
every single cell and then we quickly
switch to a curve on the bottom here
where we're doing no cell killing so on
the concentration range for drug a is a
little bit too high because in an ideal
scenario you really want your two drugs
drug a and B to have maybe one or two
concentrations that are highly active in
this way but you really want at least
two concentrations surrounding the IC 50
because it's very difficult to see drug
synergy when you have one drug that it's
acting in a very strong manner to to
cause cell filling and drugs B if you
look on the right of this successive
midgets locks you can see that drug B
concentration is actually a little bit
too low so it is actually set at a top
concentration of four micro molar um but
at four micro molar we have about thirty
percent of the cells dead so we only
have about one dose in this matrix block
that is giving activity and it's kind of
only giving partial activity you have
four doses where drug B is really not
doing anything at all um and so for this
what this does if your concentrations
are off it really minimizes the
statistic window for your assay and so
you can see that this on the right is a
delta bliss map and so that is one of
those synergy models that I spoke about
and so what it does is any area you see
that's in a dark red color that means
that well is very synergistic on any
whale you see that is in a white ish
color or has a zero value that means
that that a drug combination in that
well is not synergistic or is possibly
additive but definitely not synergistic
and so you can see that for this
fixmestick
the matrix block of atoms are a
combination there's only really one
combination that has a really strong
synergy and all the synergy is pretty
isolated to this single column these two
columns whereas if we move down to the
ten buttons the concentrations for both
these drugs were address adjusted
so drug a was adjusted down so just from
five I'm sorry just from ten an animal
atop concentration to five an animal or
and so you can see that that kind of
gave us what I was speaking about
earlier
it gave us one concentration or there's
a lot of activity but two concentrations
kind of in that middle range and many
concentrations without swimming activity
and then drugs be the concentration was
increased to five micromolar and so that
also did a really good job
it gave us two concentrations with a
really good activity but some
concentrations in the middle and so what
that did is that really increase the
synergistic window here for this
experiment and so now we have a very
large area of synergy as compared to the
6x6 where the area is very steep so
adjusting your concentration and picking
the correct top concentration is really
important on to be able to highlight
drug synergy so here's some screening
strategy options you can do one compound
versus every single compound in a drug
library and so what that requires is
that your library compounds be plated in
an acoustic format and that's a pretty
simple thing to do we just played the
library all at once we freeze down sets
of it and then once you're ready to do
this type of drug versus all screens you
just add your single drug to those
plates you set up your files and [ __ ]
and so the advantages of doing this type
of this type of setup is that it's
unbiased because you're doing an entire
trails library and it's also really
important for testing if they're looking
for strawberry purposing that you have a
disease was it only one unknown
treatment you could try that known
treatment versus everything else and see
if you get anything interesting the
disadvantage of this is that because
your library compounds are usually pre
plated um your window you're a
synergistic window may be off just like
in the concentration considerations I
was just showing you if this particular
so
on or off a maybe more or less sensitive
to the library compounds you may miss
your ability to see synergy that's one
option
another option is what we call an all
versus all so you basically just pick in
number of compounds do all pairwise
combinations this is a limited list
you're not going to get the entire drug
library but if you have a very focused
idea about what you're looking for then
you should be able to find it here by
picking compounds that are focused on
that hypothesis and doing all the
combinations so that is kind of an
advantage and disadvantages of doing it
all versus all three so then how do we
keep see on this type of data so you can
imagine that this is a heat map of 1536
well destination plate which has been
which has been run on our platform and
so you can see that this is for a 10 by
10 matrix Lassa in this blue box you
have you know two different matrix
blocks and so typically if you're doing
qht f you would look at the V prime of
this plate you would look at the signal
the background ratio on there lots of
metrics you can assess but the problem
with a doing that type of analysis on a
matrix of plate is that you are going to
have a range of activity within this
single matrix lock there isn't going to
be anything consistent armor or
shouldn't be across this entire plate
because every matrix lock is different
you have one part of the block with a
single drug in it and other parts of the
block sees two drugs so it makes it
difficult to do a typical QC analysis
another aspect of matrix things this
different than single agents streaming
is there so multiple liquid dispensing
so you're dispensing your cells your
enzymes plus your dispensing your your
assay your compounds you need to
expensive and also the scale here is
quite large as I spoke about you can see
that if you just do you know a small
number of combination so number of
compounds that really is going to
increase the amount of concentration of
combinations that you're doing a large
number plates over time um the other
thing that is important is that the
formulas to calculate synergy are not
very good at reducing error that you may
get in that particular matrix block so
for example on an if expected formula
here your drug a hat 50% response
towards B with 60% through a plus B that
30% the synergy formula or the Delta
bliss formula here that's just a change
in that list model is basically going to
be zero because that means that that
that this was not synergistic but if you
add just a 10% drip on that exact same
formula as shown above you see that you
know drug a 50% drugs be 60% but as I
said you just add 10% drift so drug a
and B you added it's 40% of cell
viability as opposed to 38 above
equation you can see that you would
actually get a value here that makes it
seem like that's a synergistic
combination so just 10% variance can
really affect your ability to quantitate
synergy so how we chose to get around
that one of our bioinformaticians here
on raj Guha and illusion they both came
up with this crowd sourcing QC metrics
for matrix plate
so what they did is they basically sent
a online survey to internal users here
at impact that do a lot of digits
streams and just as is shown on this
slide this survey asked people to rate
the quality of this major slop not
necessarily whether this block was
synergistic or not but just is this a
block that when you look at it you can
think you can trust this data so and we
were supposed to write that as good
medium of that and so what we found upon
analyzing all the survey answers he
compared the survey answer good medium
or bad to the Z prime of each of the
plates that he had taken this nature
flocks from
and so the general rule of thumb if you
have a Z prime over 0.5 and that is a
good a good assay so closer to you know
point 8 the better but what we found is
that if he actually compared the bad
medium or good responses of from that
survey to the Z Prime there was really
no correlation between bad medium and
good matrix blocks compared to B prime
of those plates you can see that you
know plates with you know point 8 Z
prime or close to point 8 z prime seem
to have you know really good really good
matrix blocks on them but they also have
some bad matrix blocks all in these
plates here around point 4 point 5 z
prime have lots of bad matrix loss but
also have some good ones on them so
using the prime alone is insufficient to
indicate the quality of each individual
interest law so what we implemented or
created was this algorithm called MPC or
matrix PC and that algorithm is more
complicated than I think I can
accurately explain but what it does and
on basic principle is it assesses 5
principles or 5 characteristics of each
individual Nature's flop it looks at the
block control so the block control of
that corner blocks that DMSO block so if
you look at this image the corner DMSO
block is right here in the in this
corner um that should be around 100%
there should be no social in here I
would not trust this matrix loss because
for whatever reason this block has lots
of cell killing in a DMSO well so this
block should have bad you see um
smoothness of the block is also assessed
so on feet and randomness as well you
can see the both these blocks kind of
have very spotty signal that doesn't
seem to be a pattern to be there to be
liability and so that is something that
we want to make sure to count as either
a medium or a bad block so we don't want
to trust the data from that it also
looks at the variance of the activity
and the monotonicity and applied that
to a machine running platform and so now
what we have is a ranking system where
we have lot we rate blocks our good
medium and bad and so bad blocks don't
have trustable synergy good blocks have
trust the bolts energy and so what we
found is that when we applied MPC to the
same matrix blocks that were in that
survey and also compare those to the sea
prawns what we found is that we fit that
blocks that have greater than a the
prompt V prime greater than 0.5 have
about 90 cent 90% of the blocks are
ranked as good and medium and about 60%
of the blocks are ranked as good only
and so that is a good indicator that if
you combine the prawns and the
individual MCC metrics and you're going
to get matrix flux that you can trust
the beta and make sure that you can
accurately judge them and then the last
large development we had to do was
create an online interface for actually
viewing this data um and so the matrix
client is the online website the URL is
listed here and then go to it at any
time all the published studies that we
have done are there and publicly
available to look at the matrix plots
for those screening and so what's nice
is you can look at each of the matrix
locks you get some drug information on
the mechanism of action and you also get
a block of the synergy models and how a
synergy models within that nation form
so basically we now have all these
requirements you have compounds with
define mechanistic classes we have
flexible and accurate compound saving
technology and we have a good data
analysis platform so how have we applied
on the C HTS to solve biological
problems these are just some figures on
how much we have done we've really done
a lot with this particular matrix is
this combination HTS platform you can
see that we have screened 400 over 450
different cell lines and malaria as well
as Ebola with also differences to buy
screen we have seven publications
currently in there are many in still in
development and so this is ongoing these
numbers will always go up on from here
um so one the very first paper that was
published with this platform it was in
PNAS is entitled hyper combinatorial
straining identifies drugs that
cooperate with a Bruton is to kill
activated b-cell like the huge large
b-cell lymphoma cell and so a Bruton it
is a BTK inhibitor and so the simple
screening technology but are the simple
strategies that used here was the stream
of rudeness versus all library compounds
which at the time was Mike 3.0 465
comments and what we found from that on
as shown in this figure from the paper
is that a Bruton it was very synergistic
with a lots of pi3 kinase signaling
modulators and so that drug combination
was further explored in animal models
and there were other results from this
paper that are being used to start
clinical child right now and so this is
one application of translational
relevance of this platform we've also
applied this on to look for synergistic
combinations for malaria and so the this
is a figure from a paper that came out
in scientific reports there were three
malarial strains and they were screened
against over 2,300 single agent
compounds and then cherry picks were
made from there and in total there were
over 13,000 combinations tested in these
three malaria strains those combinations
were then moved to animal testing and so
the big takeaway from this paper was
that on the current malarial treatment
were very synergistic with pi3 kinase in
tortoises and so this is just a figure
of the log p adjusted value of the
compounds in my blog rare e of route 5
mechanism and so you can see that if you
greet all the pi3 carnations
on together we've got you know very good
a very significant activity here and so
those were been tested in actual animals
that had been affected with malaria to
see if they were better than the
standard of care and so you can see in
this kaplan-meier curve on the right
this is looking at Paris at emia on the
left and animal survival on the right
that this compound MV PBGC 226 that was
that's a dual pi3 kinase mTOR inhibitor
that was selected for this study had
excellent survival compared to single
agent anti-malarials and but was not
quite as good as the at the standard of
care all together but if you remove one
of the compounds from the standard of
care and really look at and combine that
with the ca3 kinase inhibitor that is
exactly where you got animals that were
long surviving long after they have been
infected in the area so that is
something that's also being investigated
in clinical trials now and then lastly
this is a study that I was involved in
looking at a basic research hypothesis
and so it's known that yarn for which is
this protein shown here it
phosphorylates the PTV the tail of RNA
polymerase and allows for transcription
to be activated and so it was
hypothesized that RNA polymerase is a
direct regulator of topoisomerase once
which is shown shown right here and soto
by tom rice one is really important for
uncoiling on the DNA to allow for
polymerase to to excess assess the on
the DNA that there and start
transcription and so that was the
hypothesis that RNA polymerase is
actually directly regulating to apply
Pommery swarm so based on that
hypothesis we thought that if you
inhibit the rd4 and topoisomerase in
combination with each other that should
cause cell death because that should
prevent the activation of RNA polymerase
prevent the start of transcription and
so that's exactly what was done in this
very simple study jq1 which is shown
here is unknown VRD for inhibitors and
campus beacon which is shown here is a
known a topoisomerase one inhibitor and
so both of those were combined together
and so the so on with you that was uses
just HTC one one six it's a colon cancer
line and so you can see in this bottom
delta bliss map that when we combine VR
d4 and Cantus beacon you have a very
large on synergistic window whereas all
of the activity of the are d4 and on RNA
polymerase was shown to be involved with
Exxon for a topoisomerase
so again they created a cell line that
eliminated Exxon for from the HTC one
one six cell line to see if that would
remove the synergy and so that's what's
been strained here on the right and so
you can see that if you have a cell on
with no X on four of topoisomerase that
synergistic window which is previously
there is much reduced and in some cases
are antagonistic at certain days and so
that is a basic research application of
this combination HTS platform and so
I'll end by just saying that team
science is a synergistic and so this is
a picture of everyone in the group from
a couple of years ago um there are lots
of people on this slide the people that
are highlighted are really the key
people who really had the idea to have
this platform exist and actually
implemented it in a way and then to get
it to the point where we are now so
Craig Thomas is the leader of one of the
chemistry technologies through here and
he's the one that actually came to
compound management multiple years ago
and said hey you know I really want to
make this and the dis that he gave a
compound management was that four by
four matrix block I showed you in this
and so the person who he handed that to
was this person here Paul shin who is a
head of compound management and Paul
basically worked with all of the other
people here to kind of make this
platform you know Paul is the one that
really implemented that very first a
robotic setup he couldn't have
implemented that robotic setup without
this person here dongsung Balu who is
the software developer who made that
first play tree formatter and made sure
that we have scheduling software to
actually do things on that very early
robot raj Guha is the one who are lazy
online matrix client that allows
collaborators to view the data that
allows us to look at the analysis and
all the other people here that are
involved have had really important role
in the implementation of this platform
and without them we would not be in a
safe on that we're actually and so that
is the end of my presentation and I'll
take any questions thank you dr. Wilson
for that informative presentation we
will now start the live human detection
of the government if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on a dream to image button at the
lower left of the presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on your screen and click on the
send button
well enter as many of your questions as
we have time so let's get started our
first question is what are the
advantages of acoustic dispensing over
traditional which would have some
advantages I think two of these two of
the main advantages of acoustic
dispensing over traditional liquid
handlers um one is that it reduces the
cost the need for consumables on so most
traditional liquid handlers small volume
or large volumes involves some sort of
chip which picks up the compound and
lose it on to some one location to the
other
and so as you can imagine the more
plating you do the more tips you run
through on so that can get expensive um
the other thing that's great about
acoustic dispensing is that you are able
to use much less compound than you would
typically for over at Ithaca liquid
handler that does physical transfer of a
compound because tips usually have to go
into a certain volume in order to you
know get all the way to the to the
bottom of that of that well you have to
have a certain amount as well whereas
with acoustic dispensing you can put as
much compound as well as you need to
plate the dead volume on the plates that
we usually use is about 1.5 microliters
so you could essentially put 2
microliters in a plate and dispense
multiple 10 nano liter droplets from
that one well into whatever destination
you'd like to and then you don't need to
use anymore um so it allows you to
really reduce the amount of compounds um
that you're that you're using for
particular experiments over over a
traditional liquid handle or that uses
on
other limitations of automated community
using robotic system
yeah so some of the limitations or
challenges that we still continue to
have in our CH TFS platform is mainly
related onto software so for example the
scheduling software that I showed you on
Florio has a limitation that you cannot
reuse a source plate or any plate that
is in the same location while another
order is running that needs that same
plate so you kind of have to do a little
bit of pre-planning about your
particular experiment and how it's
running to make sure that you don't run
into a deadlock situation because what
will happen is if you have one order
running let's say it goes to reach four
plates and then there's a second order
running that at some point meets that
same plate it doesn't have to be at
exactly the same time but what will
happen is you'll reach a deadlock where
the robot will not be able to pick up
that plate that it needs and so that is
something that you just have to think
about whenever you're designing an
experiment and so we come up with a
workaround for that and that is our work
around and then we just try to plan
ahead for on situations where we need to
have the same plate being the same plate
in the same location being on those
disease we just try to schedule things
to where they will not overlap so that
there are software limitations and
obviously any software has a limitation
in that the people that develop it can't
think of every single use and scenario
that will be for that particular for
that particular software and so you
don't realize there's a problem until
there's a problem and then you have to
kind of think of a way around it or
alter your experience
so those are just some of the kind of
basic limitation
okay it looks like we have time for one
more question can high consciousness
ACU's 4c HTS
yes absolutely high content assays or
any type of assays you know we're using
cell viability assays primarily for the
most part as their sole header boat
assays but I have done imaging
experiments using our Enfield mm I've
also done imaging experiments using the
acumen that we have on our robotics
platform so this is not at all limited
to luminescent assays or assays with the
basic reality - absolutely use it for
high-content
experiment so don't don't think that
there are those types of of limitations
you really can apply this technology to
block the different types of acne
I would like to once again thank dr.
Kelly Wilson for her presentation I
would also like to thank Roberts for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through August 4 2011 3 you'll receive
an email from Robin from you know when
this webcast will be available for
replay please show the announcement will
be a colleagues who may have met the
deadline set that's all so now thank you
for joining us and you have to see you
again good bye